hey und herzlich willkommen bei einem
besonderen video hierbei clixoom es ist
nicht nur unser jahresrückblick mit
highlights wie zum beispiel flair der
sich hier ja bei uns ziemlich einen ab
gelacht hat vielen dank oder den fanta 4
die sich vor laufender kamera
geschlossen haben nein wir haben aus
einem gewinnspiel am start wo er
wirklich alle hebel in bewegung gesetzt
haben um ein ganz besonderes gadget zu
ergattern und des ist momenten die
chamäleon von pentax rs1000 eine kamera
die nicht nur in einem flachen gehäuse
14 megapixel hd video und ein 4 fach
zoom verbirgt nein das phänomenale an
dieser kamera ist ihr könnt sie zu eurer
machen der clou ist nämlich das von
cover kann man nach lust und laune
austauschen und die chancen sind nicht
schlecht eine solche kamera zu gewinnen
wir haben zehn stück davon am start ja
und so sieht sie zum beispiel aus das
habe ich selbst gemacht einfach
ausgedruckt wie das geht erklärt ich
gleich aber mit dieser kamera sind wir
direkt bei unserem ersten highlight der
graf von unheilig in habe ich getroffen
nachdem bundesvision song contest den er
ja mit einem kleinen wenig hilfe von
kriegs um gewonnen hat und da kam ein
bisschen raus wie wir es machen immer so
dicht an den stars dran zu sein wo du
bist bin ich stelle mir wieder ganz nah
er ist ja mal ein paar klicks um ist ja
der pate von unheilig ne und er verfolgt
mich überall ja ich glaube du lebst du
irgendein koffer den wird man mit haben
und kommst da raus mit den ganzen leuten
und hallo ich habe im interview klicks
tun ist das professionelle
professionalisierte stoppen ja
es hat ja auch geholfen hätte ja
definitiv also wir haben wir gewonnen
wir haben hier den bundesvision song
contest 2010 gewonnen unfassbar und das
liegt natürlich nur an klicks mit 1
wollte ich noch zu den camps sagen es
sind nämlich nicht irgendwelche kämpfe
ihr gewinnt sondern sie werden
individuell gestaltet das könnte ich
natürlich machen mit meinen etwas
einzuschränken zeichnerischen
fähigkeiten
gehen übrigens ganz einfach ist das
fotopapier dabei kann man im
tintenstrahler bedrucken oder eben
selber drauf zeichnen geht dann unter
die kunststoffabdeckung einfach auf die
kamera schrauben fertig ist die laube
aber es gibt leute die können etwas
besser zeichnen als ich zb dieser manier
ralf rothe inzwischen auch regelmäßig
bei tv total zu gast mit seinen cartoons
der hat sich übrigens auch mal gedanken
über klicks um gemacht wie ist die lage
und dieser mann wird jede dieser camps
individuell gestalten und signieren so
und wir die gewinnen könnt das erkläre
ich nach dem nächsten video ein
absolutes highlight war es am anfang
dieses jahres war bushido bei uns und da
gab es richtig ärger und das nehmen uns
jetzt mal jeder weiß dass man mich über
meine mutter auf jeden fall provozieren
kann und ich habe keinen bock dass ich
dann halt mit alice schwarzer dann sitze
und sie merkt okay ich krieg den halt
nicht über die macho schiene und auf
einmal versagt sind wir waren damals mit
deiner mutter als als kleiner junge
daran gesagt hast so und das war ein
punkt gewesen so da hätte ich gesagt
ganz ehrlich wer ins kino so hätte ich
auch so gesagt ja klar das wäre dann
auch ein punkt wo ich da nicht drauf
achtet nach motto hey lasst uns jetzt
gut miteinander reden weil wenn dieser
punkt eintritt dann gibt's nichts mehr
von wegen zeiten ändern dich und reif
und unüberlegt und entspannt dann solche
ganz eindeutig ins knie
das hat wellen geschlagen in die
boulevardpresse zu rtl alice schwarzer
hat reagieren einen offenen brief an
bushido beschrieben ihn als mutter sohn
und so weiter beschimpft also clixoom
hat er eine heftige diskussion zwischen
den beiden ausgelöst
ihr wollt jetzt wissen wir die camps
gewinnen können ich kann mir vorstellen
und es ist gar nicht so schwer ihr müsst
nämlich nur an diese e mail adresse
clixoom at gmail.com schreiben welche
highlights haben wir eben
jahresrückblick gezeigt also welche
promis und youtube tauchen hier im
jahresrückblick auf macht euch nicht
einfach schaut nicht inditex dort werden
nicht alle drin stehen ihr müsst schon
gucken wir hier alles drin vorkommt von
daher die chancen sind also sensationell
wirklich eine dieser camps hier zu
gewinnen aber es gab nicht nur ärger bei
pixum sondern auch eine menge spaß und
den hatte zum beispiel flair als er ein
video von waikiki sagte dem vw käfer den
vw käfer durch den vw fox
hast du schon wie wir keinen
schulterblick gemacht vor momo rapper
machen kein schulterblick
bombe schluss mit lustig ich muss
nämlich noch die regularien des
gewinnspiels erklären der rechtsweg ist
nämlich ausgeschlossen und
einsendeschluss ist der 31 12 2010 um
mitternacht da stoße ich auf die
gewinner an und jetzt gibt es auch noch
was sehr informatives nämlich eine menge
gelernt habe ich bei alberto als er mir
erklärt wie man ökonomisch mitgeschickt
wenn ihr keinen bock auf abwaschen okay
also wirklich absolut kein doktor wenn
ihr die teller direkt nach dem essen mit
der zunge ableckt brauchte sie weder
abwaschen noch abtrocknen heute
youtuber sind ja eine ganz besondere
spezies im gegensatz zu ich sage mal
normalen promis über sonst haben es gibt
kein management sie haben keine e mail
adresse wo sie ihre e mails lesen können
weil sie tausende bekommen sie sind echt
schwerer zu erreichen als der papst also
hat es eine weile gedauert bis ich ihn
endlich hatte unseren ersten youtuber
sami slimani herr tutorial und als ich
ihn dann traf da habe ich auch ein
blaues wunder erlebt nämlich dass er so
berühmt ist und schon auf der straße
angesprochen wird hätte ich nicht
gedacht
solch
ein ding klicks um ist ja dass die leute
bei uns ziemlich unverkrampft sind vor
der kamera wie zb die fantastischen vier
im fragen lotto kam es zu der frage wann
sie sich wirklich mal streiten und das
haben sie dann gezeigt es gab
differenzen beim autofahren weil es
motto dachte er weiß wohin es geht mich
dachte er weiß es
nicht aber du vertrittst du
vertrittst es aber so also es wurde
vertritt eine vermutung gerne so stark
dass wir glauben er wüsste wo es
langgeht und ist das gps am zeigt das
war alles nicht was du hast dem
widersprochen was es gps anzeigt und uns
auch war der gefährliche falsche route
geführt
uns und mich ist auch noch geblitzt
worden letzte worden weil wir haben alle
gewusst dass er die blitze kommt oder im
moment stelle geblitzt haben wir gesagt
ja da trifft man einen knallharten
rapper und denkt mein gott dann wird er
jetzt hier vom leder ziehen aber dann
kommt es ganz anders und man lernt einen
komplett anderen menschen kennen egal
wie spielt sich das flüchtlingen mag ich
will dein haus am wasser mit einem
riesengroßen grundstück wie hast du das
noch nicht
aber das habe ich noch nicht so weit bin
ich noch nicht so wie ich bin doch ein
bisschen viel zu sehr stadtmenschen also
noch nicht voll spießer aber du willst
es wär was ist also ich will dahin ja
ich will dahin auch wenn ich jetzt schon
haben könnte aber ich wusste ich bin zu
jung jetzt natürlich aber da will ich
ich will eines tages nichts mehr machen
muss es einfach nur mit meiner pfeife im
garten sitzen und mein leben leben was
ich weiß dass ich wie spießig das ist so
wie
ich finde es einfach nur
so legitim ich da ich möchte das gerne
manchmal wird es bei pixum auch so
richtig emotional ein beispiel ist die
kleine lara die eine bitte an den dsds
gewinner mehrzad marashi hat
das ist schon
fast ein wenig für ein
schlafzimmer lara ist single und
er schließt aber auch ganz gut ein ich
kann ja mal ein bisschen haben sie ja
nur der mann im mond schaut
wenn die kleinen
schlafen
traumschlaf
eigentlich gelten culcha candela als
eine ziemliche spaßtruppe aber das ist
wieder witzig bei pixum wenn man dann
die frage stellt wie ist die lage kommen
manchmal ganz erstaunliche themen zum
tragen also wie ist die lage war zum
beispiel ist eine frage die haben wir
noch nie vorher gehört
und das freut uns natürlich wenn wir
nicht nicht zum 5000 zehnmalige sagen
müssen was culcha candela heißt und wie
wir uns gegründet haben
okay das heißt das ist zum beispiel das
ist ich hab das mal boxen stärken als
erstes mal geschickt lässt seiner fragen
gesagt was wäre denn eine frage die er
noch nie so die er gerne gefragt werden
würde ich würde gerne mal gefragt werden
wird wie jetzt das unserer meinung nach
somit mit integration ist und so und was
wir davon halten komischerweise
krieg die
deutsche nationalmannschaft im fußball
die kriegen bundesverdienstkreuze und
wir sind seit achteinhalb jahren
gelungen ist integrationsprojekt was ich
selbst gegründet und finanziert hat
durch sage ich mal auch schwierige
zeiten gegangen ist rein finanziell
völlig ohne spenden
und die ich glaube wir sind noch ein
kuckuck uns doch mal an wie sind gute
gutes beispiel für junge leute dass man
es schaffen kann egal wie man aussieht
wo man herkommt und
wie sagen halt so wir sind die neuen
deutschen darüber würde ich zum beispiel
gerne reden manchmal bin ich was unsere
gäste betrifft vollkommen auf dem
holzweg zum beispiel beim checker
fünfter bei dsds da dachte ich na ja so
viel wird er nicht gekriegt aber es kam
ganz anders unglaublich viele klicks und
heftige kommentare was an seiner
unkonventionellen
laut da läuft countdown ja countdown
läuft zehn neun acht sieben sechs fünf
vier drei zwei eins
warum drehen mädchen durch wenn sie dich
sehen weil ich so geil bin ganz klar
ja ich bin locker sexy sehr gut aus und
deswegen stehen die mir darauf mich ist
das auch diese selbstsicherheit
mir kann keiner was auf jeden fall und
jetzt beantwortest du mir die ganzen
feier ich noch einer wartet also noch da
ist nach einer waren ja nicht doch warum
bist du so sexy
ja das ist sehr viele sport den ich
treibe
mit 73 noch
warm ein stopp ist
überzeugt
was kann da
bist du nicht zu sehr von dir überzeugt
nein bin ich nicht ich bin so wie ich
bin ich bin doch geil oder pixum
unterscheidet sich von konventionellen
talkshows noch durch eine kleinigkeit
und zwar die begrüßung der gäste die
wirkliche echte begrüßung die wird immer
mit gedreht und da gibt es manchmal sehr
lustige begebenheiten wie zb mit lena
die aso
wie ist die lage du hast du das gesehen
sehr gut vorbereitet ja du immer
natürlich die lage ist heute sitzen ja
nicht meistens wollen wir zusammen gegen
zusammenbrüche die achtung
ja
okay
das ist meine kamera
meine
na super das wird ja sensationell ja
okay ich lerne hier zum
ok
sensationell also lee nach werbung
machen ist also erst ein vertrag mit den
ok die erste frage kennst ja schon ist
die lage wie ist die lage ja
so recht gefunden in deinem neuen leben
ja danke
clixoom bildet das stelle ich immer
wieder fest manchmal hatte man so sein
eigenes weltbild und darauf basieren
auch die fragen zum beispiel die an
coldmirror
weiß oder pink gute gute trefferquote im
roten bereich das ist sein wirst du
endlich erwachsen niemals niemals
gedanken drüber gemacht hier gibt es ja
peter pan syndrom und so weiter nicht
erwachsen werden sollen wollen aber ich
bin für meinen teil also ich bin in der
art wie ich mich gäbe bin ich glaube ich
erwachsen geworden also es gibt sachen
man kann albern sein und erwachsen
werden und es gibt viele leute die sehen
erwachsenwerden gleich mit seinen humor
verlieren oder irgendwie einer
geregelten arbeit nachgehen der familie
gründen und so weiter und das mache ich
vielleicht auch irgendwann das steht ja
überhaupt nicht im weg aber ich möchte
trotzdem ein humor bewahren und ich
versteh mich super gut mit kindern die
sagen alle ich hätte dich gerne als
große schwester oder als mutter und so
und das ist dann auch im wegen
kompliment also ich weiß nicht wann ich
erwachsen werde kann ich nicht sagen ich
hoffe nie clixoom ist ein wunderhorn
voller überraschungen wie zum beispiel
bei kay one da war ich mich total
geplättet als er mir zu beginn des
interviews erklärte in welcher situation
er sich gerade befindet wie ist die lage
wie lange also abgesehen davon dass sich
gestern ja genommen noch so leichte
spätfolgen hat also ziemlich gut also
wer sich eine frau die mich nur so
leicht antippt würde so ding dann wird
auf jeden fall stehen aber du hast mal
wieder gar nicht nötig da habe ich noch
nicht aber ich dass dieses tokio hotel
phänomen was ich auch unbedingt nach ja
ich sage ganz ehrlich jetzt ist auch
kein viagra ist soziales also offen der
unterschied ziel ist es auf natürliche
ebene ist glanzlicht und klar man hat
immer wieder so von leuten die als
junger kerl ab doch so was gar nicht
nötig und ihr habt doch schon steht
kraft und das ist ja ganz ehrlich das
geht mehr ab
ich würde jetzt keinem raten bis zu
nehmen so ich nehme ich gebe es auch
offiziell zu damit hat kennt kein
problem es macht einfach spaß
es ist wirklich so tatsächlich du fühlst
mehr und die frau denkt offiziell dass
du doch konnte marco bist also ich hab
mich jetzt leider damit gelautet
youtuber sind nicht laut youtube oder
youtuber ist nicht gleich youtuber das
ist ein ziemlich buntes potpourri an
persönlichkeiten und es gibt sogar
richtige womanizer den senioren straße
ich hatte mal ein mädchen die summe
kommen hat geweint nein er lesen kannst
du mal
geweint und ich dachte
so sicher dass die rede ist ja sagst du
bist doch ich bin nicht irgendwie so
amerikanischer rapper oder so ist das
zunächst verrückt
guten umstellungen muss sich daran
gewöhnen aber ich habe mich daran
gewöhnt und es ist cool aber es
entwickelt sich weiter es wird noch mehr
also aber ist es wirklich wirklich
eigentlich ist es cool weil früher ich
sag mal so wenn ich wollte könnte ich
jetzt den ganzen mädchen so haben sagte
ich meine aber
ich tue sich noch und weiß ich nicht ich
glaube ich musste doch mal drüber
nachdenken und klickst du musst auch
eine kontaktbörse zum beispiel bei
revolverheld jakob sucht eine freundin
ja da kommt es auf der seite unserer
schlagzeile sucht er eine freundin aber
man muss dazu sagen dass jürgen auf eine
andere art und weise
damit ganz gut hin vielleicht kurzen
aufruf machen ja
ein hübscher mann ein erfolgreicher
talentierter musiker so eine herz
sucht ein nettes mädchen die für ihn
kochen wird die auf ihn zu hause warten
wird ungefähr so gebaut ist wie ich und
wie gut knutschen kann und die ihn nicht
nur wegen seines geldes will schön ende
der durchsage das war der klicks um
jahresrückblick 2010 und wenn ihr euch
jetzt gemerkt habe wer darin alles
vorgekommen ist habt ihr eine riesen
chance auf eine dieser zehn pentax
chamäleon wie ihr wisst individuell
gestaltet vom kantonisten ralph bothe so
und ich bin jetzt weg und wohin das weiß
der graf von unheilig ganz genau du
kannst jetzt wieder in deinen koffer
gehen um mit seinen leuten und dann
kommt er da raus kommen wenn man bei der
nächsten